le césar du meilleur acteur dans un
second rôle est attribué à
vincent lacoste dans
l'es4 nomination comme meilleur espoir
en 2010 pour les beaux gosses comme
meilleur acteur en 2015 près qu'au
printemps 2009 pour un mandat est en
meilleur second rôle victoria
je les tiens loustau un journaliste qui
prend 10 heures ne devrait sous son aile
et lui d'ici
vers féroce de la presse sa deuxième
incursion au fil des époques le journal
d'une femme de chambre de benoît jacquot
quand l'autre pas le 23 mars face à
ricky crips dans nos frères blessés
[Musique]
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
merci merci à tous va écouter je vais je
vais faire assez classique 1
je vais remercier xavier giannoli bien
sûr pour ce rôle de l'oustau qui était
vraiment exceptionnel de la lecture il
était vraiment extrêmement bien décrit
tout était parfait il y avait juste à
dire le texte
[Musique]
merci xavier merci de ta passion merci
de ton de ton en train de ta merci pour
ce pour ce rôle merci olivier delbosc le
producteur du film
merci la gaumont merci à vos -
bravo et merci à tous mes partenaires du
film benjamin cécile jeune salomé
xavier bien sûr monde est un peu ingrat
catégorie mais je partage ce sujet avec
toi je vais essayer de faire couper en
deux et exceptionnelle dans le film là
haut
j'ai une pensée aussi pour un jean
françois stévenin et
jeu c'était un
honneur une grande chance de tourner
avec lui
je remercie
toute l'équipe du film bien sûr
christophe beaucarne enfin toute
l'équipe tout le monde pierre jean bravo
riton bravo pour vos césar aussi
je remercie ma famille je remercie mes
amis certains sont dans la salle
certains sur scène
je remercie jo je remercie
je remercie mon agent bien sûr google
exceptionnel
tout le monde le connaît dans la salle
il ya douze nominations ce soir bravo
merci de ta patience t était un ange
mercie au somptueux mathieu derrien
aussi bien sûr ils sont devant
je remercie aussi alors j'ai moi j'ai
commencé ici mais un peu par hasard et
donc je veux remercier tous les
cinéastes qui qui qui qui m'ont donné la
chance de faire ce métier bon je vais
pas tous les citer mais mais mais non
merci ouais pendant ses jalons n'y a pas
la musique
elle arrive elle arrive
merci à vous merci aux mais merci aux
cinéastes ccc
voilà je sais c'est une chance absolue
de notre allié avec des cinéastes de le
voir la chance de l'est de les regarder
travailler et voilà et j'ai une pensée
bien sûr pour pour mon ami mon ami riad
sattouf
ces clichés j'ai commencé merci ryad
merci d'avoir été le premier à me
choisir merci de de m'accompagner encore
aujourd'hui dans dents dans cette vie
voilà allez merci vous embrasse
[Applaudissements]